hello and a very warm welcome to the
latest edition of talking germany the
show where we do just that and my guest
today is a man whose vision
is that humankind will one day spread
out and inhabit the whole solar system
and he's nodding away as i say that
the man who is nodding and the man
behind the dream is gunter writes
thank you very very much for joining us
here in berlin today it's a great
pleasure to have you with us
lovely now gunther rights is a veteran
space
researcher his speciality is the threat
posed to the human body
by radiation during space travel and he
has a measuring device on board nasa's
curiosity rover
that is currently trundling across the
surface of mars
so i think we can very much look forward
to hearing what gunter writes the
scientists and the visionary has to tell
us about travel
beyond the final frontier
um going to rise the first question i've
got for you is that
space travel which is what we're going
to be talking about a lot today space
exploration traditionally for a long
time was
exclusively the domain of the russians
and the americans
yeah in recent years we've seen other
countries coming on board as it were the
chinese and the indians what about
germany what is germany's role in all
this
we have our own space agency of course
and
i must say that of course in in europe
when we founded isa which was
around the time esa the european space
agency the european space agency this
was around
1972 around this year so we are
very much involved also we are a little
bit smaller
and we have not a budget like nasa have
here
but we have very valuable contributions
here
and we are really strong also when we
look for
the rockets ariana now yeah which is
and what we have this automatic transfer
vehicle yeah where we can
bring it with a rihanna to the space
station yeah
for suppliers very important function at
the moment
since in nasa is another capabilities
at the moment are a little bit shortened
down yeah and
meant to when we bring astronauts at the
moment it's just
exclusively through the russian
spacecrafts here
through the so use here but later on of
course spacex will take this yeah
um so so how much in these i mean we're
living in cash strap
times how much is what is the german
budget for space
research and space travel to you oh so i
cannot say exactly yeah but when i
look for the european budget yeah maybe
we are
around 10 euro per year per person or so
for the eu i don't know
this is like a number what you can say
yeah
10 billion euros yeah 10 euro per person
10 euros per person that's interesting
i think this is a i'm i'm not sure okay
this is just a number
okay so we've got the european space
agency we've got german playing germany
playing a key role in that
what about you if you were to meet
somebody a lay person a non-scientific
person on a train and they were to say
what do you do so what would your
explanation be for what you do
and for what you have done down the
years
yeah we started very early already in
the apollo program yeah
to do this research you must know that
when i was a young scientist i
had the opportunity to join a group at
frankfurt university headed by professor
booker and he
defines the first experiment to look
what
cosmic radiation because we at this time
already astronauts were
in space here just on on orbit at this
time and on the moon yeah but
also they leave the protective
earth like the magnetic field and
so it was a very urgent question for
nasa
to investigate what a heavy iron so
collected cosmic radiation
there's a lot of ions here and
especially the heavy ones yeah which can
deposit high energies and very small
volumes yeah
what is really the health effect of
those and
this was the first breaking experiment
for this yeah
and this was done in uh as
a euro as a european experiment under
the leadership of
professor picker and i joined this so my
first task was just to verify that
it's fully functioned because we should
not release some atmosphere in the air
of the
command module and so would have to be
tight so we did the test air tightening
yeah
so this was a student's test yeah and
later on
when we then were very successful at
this time most of the scientists said oh
hey what's the hell what you can see is
when you look at the path of one iron
through bio object
even if it's poor what it can do but it
was clearly shown
that this can be can provide damage to
the cell and even can kill it
yeah yeah and this was the first proof
for that and then later on
we continued this experiment and then i
become a scientist
also in this group and i managed this
experiments yeah the
later ones not apollo 17 only the test
because this was in the same year
in autumn but for the apollo series test
project i was a manager so i'm
i'm really involved in bringing it up
and doing all the testing for that
and later on also for other experiments
in this area
okay so the concentration has been on
the threat of radiation to the human
body
when displaced travel space travel how
to measure it
and how to shield the body and how to
is this we have two important points
first you have to know what is
imprinting on the human body
and then you have to look uh what what
reactions the human body shows
and how i can understand this reaction
most of things are repaired otherwise we
wouldn't exist here
because we always are irritated also on
earth
by particles but at relatively low doses
what we call it yeah
but there's always damage also from
other noxis on earth yeah even if you
press oxygen
then you have a damage in your lung and
everything is repaired yeah
and to look how this repair in involves
and
to understand how it is repaired and of
course if you have
rotation damage how to heal it here at
the end
okay thank you for that now you've had
your first impressions there from gun to
rights
before we talk some more let's just take
a closer look at two of the experiments
that he has been involved in
he's a man who likes to look not just
ahead but up
to outer space where the international
space station is orbiting the earth
physicist gunter heitz is one of
germany's leading space scientists
his department the radiation biology
unit in the german aerospace center in
cologne
researches the effects of cosmic rays on
man
and nature lights has been with the unit
since 1975
in the early 1970s he worked on various
international space missions
including nasa's apollo program
writes hopes that one day humans will be
living on other planets
for the time being one of the main
obstacles is the high radiation levels
in space travel
he developed the matoska experiment to
find out more about the biological
effects on humans
in 2004 matoska a dummy equipped with
thousands of radiation sensors
was brought to the international space
station it remained there until 2009
helping them understand more precisely
the dose and particle distribution in a
human body for an improved radiation
risk assessment
as soon as the matroshka experiment was
over gunterreitz embarked on his next
project
now age 64 the physicist is currently
involved in nasa's curiosity mars rover
mission
the rover has been exploring the red
planet since august 2012
in search of life forms
kreitz and his team developed a
radiation assessment detector
to measure radiation on the surface of
mars which is carried on board the rover
that project marks the apex of a long
and successful career
today he's our guest on talking germany
gunter rights
gunter wright's looking very very happy
in that shot at the end of that report
there yeah
it's lovely um curiosity the rover the
mars rover has been your involvement in
that project has been it was described
in that report as
as the high point of your career yeah
how exciting has it been for you to be
involved there
yeah it was a further step of course you
know you see we are on the moon yeah we
are on the iss
we are really uh
let's say permanent guests with our
rotation instruments on the iss
also know madroshka is now on ground but
we
like to refurbish it and then send it
back
together with our russian colleagues and
but still we have some location
measurements on the iss and of course
you know we have a parallel development
we had also at this time we had the
european
development the euro is exomars mission
yeah
and unfortunately this was relatively
long delayed
now we will have with 216 to 18. and
this was an invitation by the united
states scientists
from south west research institute
the university of keele and dlr you
contribute
to the detector head of this instrument
so it's
it's in u.s experiment of course with
our contribution yeah
and it's really exciting because
there's a lot of challenges to do here
to manufacture this experiment
to qualify it for this harsh environment
we have first when we have a launch and
of course we have vibrations yeah
then we have of course to survive
through also orbit
to through all the transfer and uh
then of course the landing yeah we have
also with vibrations and then
the environment on mars where it's very
cold and just tell our viewers first of
all though to
about the journey just just explain how
far the journey is what is involved
there how many days does it
what's the distance yeah but this is a
around 200 days yeah where you have to
travel yeah
and of course it's hundreds of millions
yeah of kilometers yeah
and this is and you see you have all
this opportunity when
mars is very close to the earth so it
could be very much more
yeah if we have opposite direction but
you choose your mission profile
when they are in principle in parallel
that you can
easily that you can easily reach it yeah
so
we have different mission profiles also
for that and during this difficult phase
that you're expelling
you've got take off you've got landing
you've got the journey in between all
the vibrations and everything how
nervous were you
for your device not for the device
because uh for the device we are quite
confident in the device because it's
very nicely tested so
for the journey we see no problem yeah
and
in the beginning nobody likes to have it
switched on
yeah but then we argued that it was
be a nice data set when we have the
transit phase yes and we have also
five solar particle events which we
could record yeah
and then it happens is that we are
switched on
nearly all the journey yeah and we are
very happy on that yeah so we have a
full set of measurements there already
and this makes us confident of course
for mars and for
for mars it was the only problem was to
get
a safe landing yeah and this was the
first time
you see that nasa have such uh
sick mass to be landed so the rulers
just a ton
like a normal car yeah what you have to
land safely
and it was very difficult to land it
yeah we go through different phases
was the first time that they land like
this
and certainly it was i don't know
whether it was 50 50 or so yeah
so of course we are all very intentioned
yeah
that we are safe on ground when you said
on ground of course
still you have still you have some
uncertainty yeah
because you have this push down anyway
you have a shock
yeah and then after
all the systems were checked we are very
happy that the instrument works and from
this time on
it works yes it works okay so you've
landed successfully on mars and i a lot
of people like me will assume that
probably the the main thing you're
trying to do is trying to work out
what the surface of mars is like what
new discoveries you can make but also
this
this question that we that we hear so
very often down the years is there life
on mars is that a question you've
you've really been addressing of course
yeah because
you see that beside
rotation besides rotation we also have a
group on astrobiology so we are looking
for organisms who can survive in extreme
environments yeah
and this is one part of our science so
we are very interested so on the one
hand
in the in the division we have to fight
against us because
on the one side we like to settle mars
and of course those people who like to
look
for is their life on mars they like not
to have it contaminated
so we are doing also research and
planetary protection and so
yeah so we are a little bit
divided for this question and certainly
you see
up to now we have no proof that there
was life yeah but
there is water which of course makes us
optimistic yeah
and we have also subsurface water and
maybe
there is and also when you look at the
history of mars which is uncertain yeah
there was certainly conditions where
life could involve
evolve and of course we like to look
for some signatures and this is what
amazon is doing not
looking directly for life that there's a
green men's here or
bacteria although yeah it's just to look
for the structures with
which makes the beginning of life
okay while we're talking about what
we're talking about we're talking about
mars let's uh we
we've got uh we've got some footage i
think from the from the high resolution
stereo camera on board
there we are the european space agency's
mars express with your expert eye just
tell us a little bit about what we're
actually seeing here
maybe you can just comment on those on
those images
these are of course mature at impact
it's not my field
you may see channels on mars yeah you
may see
of course construction we have no
tectonic plates here but
of course yeah you see here crater yeah
and we are also in the gale crater
of course yeah and this is also selected
a little bit
the gale crater when you have a crater
you have not
so much exchange on material with the
other
with the other area of mars yeah and
because this is planetary protection
stuff yeah so you like not to
contaminate yeah
and also we do a lot of sterilization
with the spacecraft yeah
to prevent contamination yeah which is
difficult yeah
and just give me a clue about how you
you've got you've got data coming in all
the time
from from the rover how does that data
arrive does it arrive at your office or
on your laptop or what how does that
actually work
no in principles i arrive let's see gpl
is doing this at
nasa and they disprove the data and
we have our own web page which is
running at the southwest research
institute
and here i can grab the data always
it's not a problem yeah so we have this
very nice connection and we
we grab it from southwest research
institute because it's much easier you
know this nasa is always a little bit
complicated
that you need passwords and and yeah so
it's
always difficult to get access here but
this is nicely distributed so we can
direct crap it from from from the web
page at our partner yeah
wonderful amazing to think of all this
data coming in from mars yeah
directly who would have thought yeah
it's an interesting project yeah and the
the idea is that they're going to put a
man
or men or women on
mars by 2025
is it realistic this is challenging yeah
because there's a lot lots of
uncertainties and
for me the highest uncertainty is is
that you provide a safe landing yeah so
you're working on that and
as i have seen they have countries this
because of the vibrations that you were
talking about
you have to land safe landing without
crashing yeah without crashing okay
landing without crashing and you see
when you when nasa is planning a mission
and
then we look for mass mission and
certainly we cannot be better than a 90
percent
safety that you can return safe back
at the moment i don't think that mass 1
will achieve the 90 percent but we will
see
and of course we have also for the trip
we have
radiation impact here but radiation
impact certainly will not
cause death of the astronauts going
and you can provide shielding against
unbursts
against sunburst and this is certainly
not a problem
but you have of course transfers the
cosmic radiations here which is
deeply penetrating so you have excess
exposure
and a higher risk to die later on cancer
is clear
but as i said the technique at the
moment
it's questionable yeah but uh maybe when
you say it's questionable you're talking
about this dutch commercial project what
about
what about you at the european space
agency you're talking about putting
your a manned project to mars by 2040
yeah yes that's right yeah but this is
only in the
in international cooperation i don't
think that
is that in europe also not in the united
states
they have enough money to with all this
safety which must be included yeah
so you need a lot of preparations and
so it certainly is a common mission of
all space agencies
so must one of course it's the only
thing of course it's
singing that we speed up a little bit
yeah and
you see that the money is always short
and the mass mission
costs a lot of money okay but if all the
problems could be solved the aim the
declared aim your enthusiasm is clearly
to put
human beings on mars why
yeah i would say to put humans on mars
in the future
is not a bad idea yeah because
we have to see we uh in on earth we are
in a spaceship
here and i think that mankind
we have the solar system we have all
this capability should spread over we
have done this in the past when we
didn't know
that we are bowls and so i think this is
um
really in our blood and i think it's
achievable and it's a for
for me it's also second leg on which we
stand you have seen that we have
nearby parsing of a meteorite or so
so it could happen to the earth what's
happened in the past here
that we have a major hit of uh it's not
going to do
i mean you know if a meteorite hits
planet earth
and maybe destroys life on earth and
we've got two dozen people up on
mars oh you may grow up in a colony why
not
you think so that you think this is at
all realistic yeah
i don't know you see what what what do
you think about realistic when you talk
about
somebody in in in the 800
to fly in to fly then they will say you
are crazy yeah
but of course when we look at our at our
stand of technique
at the moment it's really a problem yeah
so we are we are not so far
i would say yeah and um it's
um this when you just if
even if mars one is successful yeah
i would say this is you cannot bring up
whole colonies with these techniques you
have to be
it's interesting when i listen to what
you're saying you sound as though you
and your fellow scientists are actually
very
pessimistic people because it sounds as
though i mean we've been given the
planet that we have it's a perfectly
nice hospitable environment by and large
yeah
it sounds as though we're going to sort
of get it all wrong here on planet earth
and we're going to need another planet
sometimes i have the feelings that we're
doing everything wrong
but okay but certainly uh
i i think mankind should spread over and
there's a nice
that we uh know in the age that we
should leave our cradle
where we are born and
to uh spread over the solar system i
think this is
uh as human mankind like to know how the
universe is built you can say
why you are interested how how how the
origin of the
universe worked you have a nice place
here i don't know you cannot go
to to sons like vega or you cannot go
why you are interested in and you see
it's deep in us
and we like to to to to excellent
examine this yeah and we like to have
knowledge in this
how life
how life is is uh really appeared here
why we should know this yeah okay yeah
but we are looking for that and
we like to see the first life forms and
we like how everything
is developed yeah this is our basic
knowledge we're looking for astronomy
nobody
yeah when you look at this far away
galaxies you can say oh i can never go
there but it's fantastic
it's fascinating okay what about this
one yeah fascinating it is that's for
sure and i understand your enthusiasm i
can feel your enthusiasm but
there are there are two sort of groups
of people involved in space exploration
there are
there are the technicians that are the
people responsible for the machinery and
the experiments
that's you and there are the astronauts
who actually fly out i mean obviously
they're technicians too but they
they actually go there what's your
relationship to the astronauts do you
envy them
in your heart of hearts
no i i i had never the intention to go
in space
yeah i must say we worked very close
with astronauts because
in my working time we have built a lot
of experiments here and of course
these experiments need to be operated in
a spaceship here whether it was a
shuttle or the iss
so we have close contact to the
astronauts because we have to teach
them how to do the work with our
experiments that we have
optimal results and so so i i have a
close contact with them yeah yeah
to the newer ones not so much because
when we have an experiment of course
they come to us we have the
european astronaut centers here so it's
easy to go over yeah and i know a lot of
people of course i'm long in the
business
perry rhoden is clearly very popular
here in germany
people who haven't read the comics yeah
what have they missed out on
what's the appeal this i don't know
but i i i come to it
accidentally when i was a student here
and
um so all the physicist students
reading paul rhoden you know when there
was a lesson spice professor
so so i saw this and so i i
jumped in and then at the end i said
okay
this was 1968 yeah or so
yeah and so i i look at the old book
shops here and
of course i get all the previous numbers
yeah so i actually read number one
and so you began at number one and
you're still reading today
i'm still reading today yeah really once
a week once
not always once a week sometimes i let
this
moving up sometimes i was 10 behind but
i
i i with this small shop they will store
it yeah
and then i come and pick it up every
four weeks or so
two thousand two thousand seven hundred
editions
and more i am told yeah seven three four
tell me about perry rhoden who to tell
the you know what's he like
yeah but yes it was a person perry
rhoden of course he is always a lucky
person because at the end he wins
this is not a reality certainly but
of course it's the main person and they
had some problems for the
in in the first he was always uh let's
say he's a leader yeah but
then sometimes it changed a little bit
because
so also has like not to have him that he
is always
making the decisions here and so he left
but he
always kept his contact with this uh
because he has this what we
call this this small equipment
which prevents that he never becomes old
here
and a very useful gadget very useful
gadget yeah i would like to have it of
course
but it's but it's also you have also
some pain with it if the others die
you're still alive there you go but
talking about gadgets is the science
in the series good they do their best
and they do that so do their best yeah
because of course they cannot
follow the science because as we said
it's science fiction yeah
so of course i cannot travel through
black holes also yeah
and of course we have this very rapid
transportation system yeah where you go
in
in in in equipment then you are
dissolved and then you appear at other
places
in zero time this would like being
beamed up in star trek yeah
like this yeah like this and this is of
course
these techniques we do not have we might
get there one day yeah
here's an interesting question for you i
i made an interesting discovery reading
up on perry road and i discovered that
uh
it's been translated into many languages
it's still very popular in some areas
around the world outside germany
sold over a billion copies do you know
the first language that it was
translated into
as a perry roden expert i'm not sure but
i think it's english
but not okay no there were four
editions that were translated into
hebrew
and that was the first foreign
translation sometime in the 1950s 1965
that was a very interesting little thing
yeah yeah okay this was before i started
yeah
that looks like a great project uh tell
us more
yeah we have uh initiated school lap
in a couple of years ago in 2000 i think
it's the first one in gottingen
then soon berlin and
of course our school lab in our
institute follows yeah with the last one
we have seen here
in dresden and of course it should bring
the people you know the young people
to make them interesting in such
questions like origins of life
how a plane is flying why it's flying
yeah
what are the future energies we have all
really fun from the mental questions and
say uh it's a real hands-on we have a
lot of a lot of experiments there yeah
where they can see a lot of nice effects
they never
in our case yeah how small
animals are moving let's say in a field
where the
gravity is not there or where we can
simulate it in non-gravity yes it says
being very different and so
and all these nice things to give them a
hands-on and we follow up this so we
cover this
for the smallest age as you have seen
it's
10 11 yeah then it makes sense and also
to higher classes and this is the start
on of course
one major effect is that people come
back here
and we have also in dlr besides the 12
school labs here
we have also programs and
for diploma works for thesis works yeah
so we are also educating people so you
can also come to
dlr also in my lab to make masters
always we offer practica
yeah so young people can come to make it
practical so we spend this time
to educate them hoping that they come
back later on
when you talk about i mean it's all
fascinating stuff when you talk about
young people
yeah making science attractive for young
people so that they're going to come
along and they want to work in that
field
are you also talking about young girls
because i i mean i have a daughter who
is 18
yeah and and i can see in her circle the
boys are still
you know often the girls are the real
achievers in the classroom but the boys
are the ones who are going off towards
science
and like that girl in the in the report
the girls are going off to do other
things like
journalism or whatever you know but
nevertheless that's a problem
yeah but nevertheless you see we have at
the moment we have two
thesis forex and physics yeah two women
and this was after selection procedure
so people could apply for the space love
program
and we have a lot of young female
students here which apply for that yeah
and of course you know the dla has also
the girl's day
so we are doing a lot of things you're
trying out it's no longer
necessarily a man's world yeah right
okay talking of um science
uh experimentation and what have you
we've had this object sitting here all
the while
you've brought it along for us to have a
closer look at it yeah
um explain what it is yeah this is a
looks like a simple cam but this was the
first european experiment here
under the leadership of my previous
previous leader professor dr booker
where we looked for the effects of a
single heavy iron
on biological materials
since we have no life support so we use
resting systems
like spores yeah so you can survive for
very long time
yeah and we uh in principle assembled it
between
nuclear tract detectors which are able
to show which radiation is going
through yeah and so we could design this
and we could show
first time that one heavy iron yeah
is capable to damage or even kill the
cell yes this was
and this was the highest priority
research at this time for nasa
therefore they select us here and of
course we have not the staple in
yeah but this is one experiment which
was
already on apollo and of course we uh
we looked at this it's a piece of
history and we assembled all these names
of the previous co-investigators
so this was in international cooperation
this went out into space this went out
into
spread not out in space but that did
that existed into orbit
yeah so orbit on the moon yeah
for the 1670 we are in the command
module
and this as a scientists here taking
part in this
and you see that this is also at this
time international
cooperation we had also u.s scientists
yes yeah
we are now have corporations all over
the world with japanese with us
with russia yeah especially also
now china is coming yeah of course
okay and so we'll see how it develops
but still there's a lot of open question
in rotation biology
so biology is not a simple system
as we have heard certainly before in the
other
session but this is the same with this
radiation effects yeah
okay we've talked we talked about
germany uh and we've talked about young
people in germany we've talked about
your role in the in the space industry
in germany in the broadest sense
um we've talked about the european we
talked about
yeah the european space agency just tell
me this
at the end of the show would you say
that germany
is a space nation are the people in
germany behind you do they understand
why you need
big sums of money to do to put people
where you put them to carry out the
experiments you carry out
i would hope that our politicians
understand this yeah
but we are very strong in space science
yeah because we
as as you said we have a lot of good
techniques here and we have
very strong companies here and also dlr
is strong
and have a lot of knowledge in space
science so i
of course would like to have it more
supported
i bet you would yeah and on that very
optimistic
i'm going to say that's your lot with
the passionate the visionary visionary
space
researcher gunther rights there's more
talking germany including my blog
and our archive on our website if you
have enjoyed today's show as much as i
have then do come back next week until
then bye bye and
cheers
you